[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i'm very excited for this episode and
i'm going to skip my usual preamble to
jump straight to the guest my guest
today is anne lamott you can find her on
twitter and instagram at anne lamott
that's a-n-n-e-l-a-m-o-t-t
ann uses honesty empathy and humor to
write about our world in her beloved and
best-selling books like operating
instructions an account of her son's
first year bird by bird her classic book
on writing and i will have a fair amount
to say about that and help thanks wow a
celebration of prayer lamont delves into
what makes us human she explores the
wide experience of life that unites us
birth and death parenthood and family
faith and doubt love and loss
forgiveness and hope in each of her 19
books which have sold millions of copies
worldwide le mans brings her distinctive
mix of bracing candor clarifying insight
and refreshing humor to convert serious
subjects like addiction motherhood loss
and faith into human truths we can all
share she is the author of several essay
collections on faith including traveling
mercies grace parenthetically eventually
and plan b as well as several novels
including imperfect birds blue shoe and
rosie lamotte has been honored with a
guggenheim fellowship and has taught at
uc davis and writing conferences around
the country
she is an inductee of the california
hall of fame and the subject of academy
award-winning filmmaker freda mock's
documentary bird by bird with annie from
1999. her most recent book is dusk night
dawn subtitle on revival and courage
annie
welcome to the show it's so exciting
that you are here and we're finally
connecting
thank you tim i'm so honored and i just
want to say i think my son takes me a
lot more seriously because you were
interested in having me on
oh well wait until he hears the back
story
and
i was very happy to meet sam just a few
minutes ago before we started recording
and the back story is as follows when i
was working on my first book four hour
work week
the blessing and curse that that title
has always been but at the time
pre-publication working on this book and
i made it about
halfway or two-thirds of the way in and
realized holy [ __ ] this structure the
entire
lattice work that i thought i had
created so perfectly is not going to
work at all and then i proceeded to
promptly have
in retrospect it was probably a complete
nervous breakdown began self-medicating
with copious amounts of caffeine and a
little bit of alcohol at night
and went into this spiral of self-doubt
and loathing and was absolutely
convinced i was going to have to throw
in the towel return the advance
lick my wounds and move on and someone
gifted me bird by bird and this cannot
be the only time you've heard this but
it proved to be an invaluable life raft
or maybe some type of resuscitation
device maybe both
and it is i would say no short measure
one of the most important components
that allowed me to finish that book
furthermore
the years following
led me to meet many people including
friends like ramit seti and when he was
writing his book he also crossed this
rubicon and landed in the territory of
self-loathing and was going to do the
same thing he was going to quit he just
thought there was no way out he was
trapped in a maze gave him bird by bird
he was able to finish and his book
became a new york times bestseller and
you must hear this
all the time and i'm going to ask a
question that no doubt you've been asked
before but i have to ask
what do you think it is about bird by
bird
that affected so many people so deeply
and certainly that's true of many of
your other
works but in this particular case what
do you think it is that
has that type of effect on people
i think it's because
i didn't try to con people into thinking
that if they just got a book finished
that my agent would want to take a look
at it by the end of the week and that it
would almost certainly be published and
that then they would
all the swiss cheese holes inside of
them would be healed and they'd be well
and they'd get that fda stamp of
approval and be validated and then their
parents would start to respect them i
said none of that's going to happen all
of that is an inside job but
i'll tell you a funny story when sam's
little boy who's 12 now was five i was
teaching his kindergarten class a
writing workshop and instead of saying
shitty first drafts i said really poopy
first drafts but after and the kids
loved me and after i was done my little
grandchild came up to me and he leaned
in and he sounded like tony soprano he
said oh nana that was terrible and i
said what and he said you told people
you would teach him how to write a book
but you only taught us how to write one
page
and that's really what i can help you do
is one chapter is on shitty first drafts
i i don't try to teach kids or grown-ups
how to write really really well i just
teach them to stop not writing i teach
them to keep their butt in the chair and
to write badly and that all first drafts
of any book you've ever read by the
authors you esteem most began as
unreadable first drafts and i teach
people to take it really small you know
bird by bird is it okay if i tell the
story please please i i i would love for
you to tell the story just so people
know the genesis
well my older brother i was like a
superstar achiever in school and my
older brother hated school and he was
kind of a rebel and in california in the
50s and early 60s
in fourth grade you wrote two term
papers one was the sacramento paper
that's our state capital and the other
was on birds and you had to write it all
year all semester a paper on birds and
my brother hadn't started it was due on
a monday and on a saturday he admitted
to my dad that he hadn't started my
brother was a tough guy and he was in
tears and my dad sat down with him and
put his arm around him and he said just
take it bird by bird buddy you know
first you read about chickadees and then
you write a paragraph in your own words
about chickadees and then you draw a
picture and then you take pelicans and
you study up on pelicans and then you
write a paragraph or a passage on
pelicans
i never ever forgot that and then years
later probably 20 years ago so
in my 40s i heard el doctoro say that
riding was like driving at night with
the headlights on you could only see a
little ways in front of you
but you could make the whole journey
that way and i think that is the most
profound advice i can offer anyone on
any topic
that you you you can only see a little
ways in front of you and and you can
make the whole journey that way and
another another thing that i think
helped people when they read bird by
bird was
the chapter on perfectionism and how
perfectionism is the voice of the
oppressor it's the voice of the enemy
and if you listen to it keeps you crazy
for your entire life because because we
all fall short you know you've written
books and you think you're creating this
golden and crystal palace that people
can walk inside of and see all of truth
and beauty and reality and you kind of
end up your books and my books all all
of them are kind of shanty towns you
know and like indeed
during the peace marches where people
set up tents and thought it made sense
to bring their dogs you know during the
rainstorm and that's a miracle to
written a shanty town and so i think
these ideas of not knowing what you're
doing
and of letting yourself do it really
badly
and to try to help
grind down that critical voice i'll just
mention my husband's
work here he's uh neil allen he wrote
shapes of truth and the work he does
with people and these shapes of truth is
taming the inner critic and what his
position is you're never going to get
rid of it you know we don't get over
very much here
what he does with people is he has him
bring forth the inner critic and
actually just put it on the table in
front of him and he he thanks them for
keeping them him alive when he was six
and seven because it kept him small and
controllable so he didn't run out into
the street he didn't swim out past his
ability to stay afloat but that at the
age of 60 or whatever we probably don't
need it anymore and so
he has his clients give the inner critic
a great new job which might be ethical
consultant for the project so that the
inner critic can go off to the library
where there's an incredibly comfortable
chair and a good reading light and 2 000
books and he will sit there and read
which he loves to do and when we need an
ethical consultation we'll come get him
but we don't need that constant is it
allow okay to say the f word on oh
yes please oh in bird by bird there's a
whole chapter on k [ __ ] radio kfkd and
without a lot of help and a lot of
transformation and healing
k [ __ ] radio is on 24 7. it's telling
you how far short you're falling it's
telling you how great you started out
and what a disappointment you've turned
out to be it's telling you that what
you're in the middle of is beating a
dead on and on and on and so the shapes
of truthwork and the inner critic work
and bird by bird is
90 percent
about turning down k [ __ ] radio anyway
out of the left-hand speaker is all this
stuff about
that you you can't do it perfectly and
that why bother and that this has been
blah blah blah but out of the right-hand
speakers it's like the voice of the
people who love you most the voice of
like for me sam or my husband or my two
best girlfriends and they're saying i
love your stories i love how you write i
can't wait to read more so but you can
turn down the left-hand speaker and
it'll always be there to some degree
there are many different directions i
could go
and
thank you for that context i am going to
sit down and re-read bird by bird in
fact which i've read at least
i would say a dozen times but i'd always
written
non-fiction and i'm beginning to
experiment with fiction which is a whole
different sport it would seem
freeing in many ways
i can help you can help me
i i if you want someone to help you
i will help you
because it's all the same stuff you sit
down you keep your butt in the chair you
take one passage one memory one vision
one bit of dialogue one character and
you do it badly
[Laughter]
so
if we look back
to your childhood my understanding is
you had a role model for this this
button chair time could you tell us a
bit about your childhood yeah
well the
model was my father who was a writer
kenneth lamotte and he had a lot of
books published in a lot of magazine
articles and
i heard him down at his desk at that old
olympia at 5 30 every morning rain or
shine or hangover he just did it and
that was what he taught me was that you
don't wait for inspiration
it's an illusion and in fact i gave a
talk once on inspiration and on how i
don't believe in it and how what gets me
going is
debt mental illness
desire for revenge
but my dad just did it and that's what i
learned and that's what i passed on to
my son and my house was very very tense
my parents didn't love each other my
father drank a lot my mother was very
very overweight and a black belt
codependent from liverpool
and i was the middle child i have an
older brother and a younger brother and
it was up to me to help make sure dad
kept coming home because he didn't like
mom but he loved me i had a rebellious
older brother and an infant baby brother
and i needed to try to help raise the
baby brother i mean my parents really
would have been better off raising
orchids or
teacup poodles or something and so what
i did at the age of five was to try to
raise the baby and to try to keep my
brother from imploding and it was
exhausting and i got migraines at five
years old and no one it was 50s no one
quite noticed that children had mental
health diagnoses and stress that was
really life or death but i'll tell you
my family worked better when i had a
migraine because families do well if
there's one sick person that's not them
so when i had to be in the total
darkness with cold compresses the family
thrived you know
but i learned a couple of rules and i
know you've written about stuff like
this but i learned some survival tools
and one was to think that i was
defective and that i was the reason that
the family wasn't doing well because if
i was the problem that meant i had some
measure of control right i could do
better and i couldn't do better i was an
a student i was a tennis star
but if i i believed i could do better
and i could need less
and if i did better and needed less then
it seemed to make mom and dad better and
it was completely reaganomic trickle
down like if dad was okay and we helped
dad pump up
then mom would be able to nurture the
three of us so
born to die people pleaser i got all of
my self-esteem from outside from good
grades from being the star of the
classroom and from being a great
conversationalist that my parents like
to have around and that my parents
friends like to chat with
and i was not only defective and this is
where it gets dicey but i was
in charge of everybody's happiness you
know i was in charge of of helping mom
not feel so put down by dad i was in
charge of making dad come home because i
was so adorable and i rubbed his feet
i'm a lot older than you but when i was
coming up in the 50s the men
they all were socks with garters these
little sock garters and i was like a
little geisha girl with curly kinky hair
and i'd sit and i'd take off his little
garter on the couch and i'd take off his
sock and i'd rub his feet and i thought
he would come home for that and he drank
a lot so what i got good at was pleasing
people being a stratospheric achiever
but not quite so
bright that it ruined my older brother's
life and it made him feel like a loser
and i know how to raise babies and i
know how to get by on the leftovers on
whatever was left over after i gave
everybody the very very best parts of me
so all of my books including bird by
bird and operating instructions
everything has to do with that
coming into radical self-care and
becoming my own priority this is kind of
funny my mom who is a black belt as i
told you codependent always took the
broken fried egg my entire life i can
swear
on a stack of bibles my mother never
once said here's somebody else take the
goddamn broken egg yolk can you take the
you know my mother ate the broken egg
yolk and that's what i was raised to
believe women did and i had to have
enough therapy enough recovery i've been
clean and sober 35 years now and enough
in the women's movement and a lot of
outside help so that i could be my own
priority and if there was a broken egg
yolk maybe it wasn't my turn again maybe
sam should have the broken egg yolk sam
loves the perfect fried egg you know
what tough [ __ ]
i know that sounds like a loving
christian thing to say but it had to do
with becoming my own priority so that
was the childhood i had i was very
afraid i had migraines i was too smart i
was very good at math girls weren't
supposed to be i skipped a grade i made
the boys feel bad because i was better
at math than they were i was small and i
looked funny i had this crazy
pure white blonde kinky hair and these
huge green eyes i weighed about 20
pounds till eighth grade and you know
all i knew to do was to do better and to
try to do it perfectly and that's why i
think the chapter in bird by bird is
something that people so relate to
because
like in my family
all of us in the american way in fact
but in my family the theme was forward
thrust that no matter what was going on
you keep going you keep going forward
you thrust forward and so that the abyss
doesn't open up at your feet you know
and and if the abyss threatens to you
you get ikea and you buy a cute throw
rug you know you pick out people and
they call the abyssi abyss because it's
pretty abysmal it's a nightmare so you
try not to land in it what my family did
was drink and overeat and diet my dad
had a million affairs
and it turned out and you've written
about this
that the abyss or in the christian you
know theology of saint john the divine
it's the dark knight of the soul
is where transformation most often
happens and that if you can just bear
being somewhere that you've never been
before where you don't really have any
kind of owner's manual or a clue of how
to proceed then you're really teachable
you know and from that place something
magical might just grow
i want to ask you
a few questions that are going to be
interrelated so i'll tell you what they
are and then we'll come to the first one
so you asked me a question before we
began recording you asked me several
questions you asked me how i was doing
you also asked me if i was spiritually
fit
or feeling spiritually fit i don't
remember the exact wording but i'd like
to hear to you what that means
and then after that
what it means to you current day after
that i'd love for you to tell us the
story
or any story of
a dark night of the soul experience that
you've had
that helped to catalyze this radical
self-care but let's start
in the present tense spiritually fit
what does that mean to you well
spiritually fit means i'm in my body
paradoxically
it doesn't mean i'm in some ether world
of you know divine enlightenment and it
means i heard a preacher years ago
say the 23rd psalm which is the lord is
my shepherd i shall not want but she
said the lord is my shepherd i shall not
trip
and i just love that because when i'm
spiritually not fit i'm just
tripping you know i'm making up stories
i'm in fear i'm in anxiety i have a i
have a tremendous anxiety disorder for
which i'm successfully treated most of
the time but i'm just tripping on
something somebody said that it's stuck
in my craw on something i'm afraid of of
something a lot of fear in recovery
there's some great acronyms for fear
because people like my coke head friends
i mean i'm my own coke head friend but
they would say that the false evidence
appearing real which usually means that
you're at the window peering through the
drapes thinking that there are there's a
swat team on your lawn at four in the
morning you know and that the only the
best idea you have is another cool
refreshing beer but some of the ones i
love is one is the frantic effort to
appear recovered that's my main thing is
that when i need to look good
when i need to appear to be doing well
is when i'm at my most spiritually
lost and another one i love is future
events already ruined and so i'm just
tripping out like i was tripping up this
morning about what if i screwed up with
tim you know and and you're so
illustrious and your
listenership i think is younger and why
would they want this old lady with
dreadlocks his sunday school teacher
where do our zen diagrams meet and i was
tripping and then i remembered you know
future events already ruined that's not
true that's just k-fuck radio and
another one i love is fear expressed
allows
relief and so i told hill and he said
you know you you are so wonderful at
this just breathe and go for a walk
first and do what you do and you'll be
sitting there with sam and tim is great
and you're going to love it it's going
to go by so quickly but so fear express
allows relief so
spiritually fit for me is that i'm not
tripping and that i'm breathing
when i was a child i didn't breathe you
know i held my breath because for all
the reasons i told you
and i remember i used to pass out on the
boardwalk in town
at three years old and my dad would
nudge me and say annie annie and i blink
awake but if you breathe you may end up
in your body and it may be that in your
body terrible things happen to you and
if you're a girl
addict an alcoholic like i am you know
until
1986 you let terrible things happen in
your body you encourage terrible things
if you let people do anything at all
that they want they seem to like you
better briefly you know and so breathing
will bring you into your body so for
that reason
you may resist it but for me to do what
i call the sacrament of ploppage and to
sit down and for one minute
to breathe into my heart cave
and do the do the sighing
i get my sense of humor back you know
and laughter
even at my own
quirky fearful darling self laughter
i've written in a number of places this
carbonated holiness so if i'm breathing
and i've gotten my sense of humor back
i'm in something
spiritual i'm something that has to do
with my human spirit and the divine i
mean i believe and and i've i've heard
that we have dual citizenship you know
we're we're children of the divine we're
children of sons and daughters of god
and we also have these
kind of screwed up biographical
details we've got genetic details that
we would have maybe not preferred we
have predispositions to alcoholism and
mental illness or to weight gain in our
thighs or whatever but i have to
remember that i can toggle back between
dual citizenship
between
being a child of god or of the
great universal spirit and annie lamont
67
sunday school teacher and left-wing
activist mother and grandmother and you
know i got married at 65 i got married
three days after i got medicare and
those are my true biographical details
and i also am a person of spirit so
that's what spiritually fit means for me
is that i remember that i'm not
this terrible pinball machine in my mind
cranking out new ideas about how i can
do life more perfectly so that everybody
will think more highly of me
annie i want to tell you
i am
enjoying this tremendously so you are
exceeding every expectation so
uh i'm
very very happy that you're here and
thank you for making the time to be here
you mentioned this radical self-care and
having written a lot about radical
self-care and what a contrast that is to
your
early experiences or earlier experiences
in life was there or is there a
particular catalyzing event
that brought
radical self-care into focus as a
imperative for you well two things
spring to mind i mean i could write a
whole book
on the dark knight of the soul and every
book i've written is about it to some
degree but it's my favorite topic and
i just had a million dark nights of the
soul while i was drinking and using and
usually the solution then was to have
eight or nine social
vodkas and maybe a little anal nitrate
just to socialize but then in 1986 the
fourth of july weekend i had a three day
blackout which is so unfair i'm not
kidding because
usually you have a blackout and you know
it's like a wet chalkboard eraser has
come by and there's nothing left on the
chalkboard of what you did that evening
and it's very scary but usually they
don't happen all that often
i had three in a row july 4th july 5th
and july 6
and i woke up in terror
the morning of july 7th and i had run
out of any more good ideas
all i could think of was how i could
figure out a way
to learn to drink more successfully
and i knew that i wasn't going to be
able to break that code and i was
already a believer i mean i've pretty
much been a believer my whole life i
already had a church by then i um i was
just done i'd reached the end of my rope
that's what the dark knight is you've
run out of any more good ideas
and in that space of total emptiness
and lostness
i was lost and something found me
and i have to think of it as grace
i understand
grace to be spiritual wd-40
and that
it spritzes you
maybe a really quick spritz or maybe it
maybe you get that
the little thin red straw inserted into
you and you get a sustained
spritz of it but
it was like water wings i suddenly
understood that i wasn't gonna sink
completely
but that i needed a lot of help
and that was a huge breakthrough for me
well the help i got first
i got
a couple of sober women who said i have
what you have
and i found a way out one day at a time
not drinking just for the day and if
your ass falls off
we can help pick it up and carry it to
where we are and we'll sit together and
we'll share our truth and you won't have
to drink for the rest of the day and
we'll help you get through the day just
without a butt
the amazing thing about grace
is that it meets you exactly where you
are
and then it doesn't leave you where it
found you
you know it sort of tricks you into
getting into its wheelbarrow and then it
moves you to some place where maybe
there's just a shaft of light or maybe
there's cool water
and the cool water i found was other
sober people but that was the darkest
night i can remember
and then here's here's a recent example
my son and his son live here
in a barn on the property and his son
lives with him half time and with the
child's mother half time and i was in
major major people pleasing and i was
dancing i was just dancing as fast as i
could to make sure everybody's needs
were met and i was taking the leftovers
and the broken egg yolks and i was
exhausted i was in existential
exhaustion and it had been going on for
a while
and i finally
i know i shared it with my older brother
who'd stopped by who's a fundamentalist
christian and he he sort of basically
done the equivalent of handing me some
nice christian bumper sticker about how
god never gives you more than you can
handle which i think is a total crock
and i think what you got to do with god
is to convince him that you really can't
bear all that much like when you deal
with a trainer at the gym you don't want
them to know how much you can lift
because they'll make you lift it and
that what you have to do is instead to
just pretend you can't pause and hint at
liability from another gym you went to
where they made you live too much
when my brother handed me this stupid
word bumper sticker i lost it
and i said to him like one of the
coneheads i said i have to go right this
minute now and go for a ride i have an
errand to do and my older brother looked
at me like what
and i got in my car and i drove out to
the woods and screaming and shouting and
pounding the steering wheel and it's
saying i hate you sam i hate you
to his mother i hate you john who's my
older brother i hate you mom and dad you
taught me that i'm a piece of [ __ ]
unless i'm getting a's and unless the
entire world and i i hated everybody and
i it was half hour
i turned around half hour same record
and then finally i pulled over to sign
the road and and i i called my my
spiritual mentor whose name was horrible
bonnie and that's what i call her anyway
and i said i hate i cannot stand it all
i do is be there for everybody else and
i get nothing i know and i went on and
on and she listened which is the miracle
that somebody listens and they don't try
to save or rescue or fix you or horse
you into submission to what they think
would be a good path for you
and she said annie this is what we paid
for
this is where i hoped you would get some
day
and i wasn't in cute adorable crying i
was in red-faced swollen nose carl
mauldin snotty crying i said no but i
don't have any i don't have i've tried
everything blah blah blah blah
she let me cry and she said you are
everybody else is your priority that
your son and your grandson and your mom
your relatives and that your best
friends and that your people at church
and the blah blah that everybody else is
taken care of and you get leftovers
and it was the darkest snottiest wettest
dark night of the soul and it wasn't
like god reached down with this magic or
his or her magic wand and tapped me it
really hurt
i was really angry about what i've put
up with and i was sad and angry and
freaked out and we just stayed on the
phone and then all of a sudden i could
breathe again
and i drove back to my house and i
became my own priority and my older
brother was there and he goes hi you
seemed kind of i said oh no i didn't you
know oh no i'm fine and frantic effort
to appear
but from that point on i can tell you
what date that was because
three months later i met the man who
became my husband i did three months of
this radical self-love of being my own
priority of letting everybody else take
the leftovers of putting myself first of
structuring my days around what would
make me happiest what i needed to do and
what i hoped to do and what i love to do
and then i would find time for everybody
else and three months to the day later i
met neil
for our first coffee date and that was
five years ago we haven't been apart for
a day since
so that was the most recent dark night
of the soul my son who's right here had
a very long stretch of meth and alcohol
where i thought he would die that was
the most terrifying thing to think i
could lose him because
he's my outside heart you know i think
children are our outside heart and i
couldn't save him i couldn't fix him i
couldn't rescue him i couldn't really
help him
but the darkness of our soul was that he
had a two-year-old child he had a baby
at 19 and the mom and my grandchild were
living it with me
and sam was around but he had a house in
the tenderloin
he had an apartment and he showed up
wasted and i had reached my bottom
that's what the dark knight is you've
run out of any more good ideas and so
what i did was i took a sharpened pencil
and i held it to his throat i mean this
does not jibe with my spiritual books my
my persona and my being hundley school
teacher and i said you're as bad as any
junkie i know and you cannot be back on
this property with your baby if you so
much as have a hit of marijuana
and we just looked at each other and he
looked at me like with such hatred and
for your child to hate you is about as
bad as it ever gets
and then i got some sort of holy spirit
nudge or
something you know the great universal
spirit and i said do you want to ride
back to the city
and to the tenderloin i don't know if
you know what the tenderloin is oh i do
i lived in san francisco a long time but
a lot of people don't so could you
describe it please not lovely it's where
all it's where all the
the crackheads and heroin at it's a
really deprived depleted
addicted prostitute pimp
terrible terrible place and anyway so i
drove him back to his house and he got
out of the
car
and he hated me
and i walked over to him and i reached
for him
i took a chance you know they say
courage is fear that has said its
prayers we hadn't said a word in the car
it's an hour drive
and i i just kept praying in silence in
the car and we stood together and i
reached for him and he reached for me
and i i said i'll see you and he said
i'll see you
and then he called me three weeks later
and he said i've got a week clean and
sober and the guys who could actually be
there for him which was not his
incredibly crazy mother who had had it
these guys in san francisco who were
clean and sober had fished him out of
the trough you know and one day at a
time had helped him get clean and sober
and he hasn't had a drink or a drug for
10 years now so
those three things that i've described
are what are the darkest nights of the
soul that i've been to but to sing with
sam and with my child in general
is that i had thought up until then that
i had some real i have a disease of good
ideas usually for other people and i
believe that my ideas will really help
them have better lives and at least make
me less uncomfortable when i'm around
them
and i learned that my help was not
helpful to sam and that help
is the sunny side of control
and i was trying to control him and that
was making him worse
and i still you know i'm 67 he's going
to be 32 this year i still he's on his
hero's journey
with his podcasts hello humans that
you've listened to and he's doing a
beautiful job and i would still
like to get on his hero's journey just
maybe 10 feet behind him with juice box
and sunscreen maybe and just be there in
case he needs me but when i do that it's
injuring him it's not helping him it's
certainly not helping me but what i have
to do is is the awareness that i'm doing
it again and grit myself gently by the
wrist and say annie
stop get back onto your own emotional
acre he's doing great he is a miracle
that's what has come from the dark
knights are the the greatest truths i
know
that my my help is not helpful
that when i'm in the darkest
most scared place on earth if i can not
try to do the forward thrust and try to
redecorate the abyss that i'm gonna get
blessing and light and i'm gonna get
fresh air
so and i'm get you know my life is if i
can tough it out or let somebody into it
with me and breathe and do left foot
right foot left foot breathe that my
world is going to become more spacious
so i want to i want to
underscore a few things and follow up on
a few things the first that i want to
note is
sam's podcast as you mentioned i
recently listened to his episode on the
how to human podcast and people can find
many interviews online at hellohumans.co
that's dot co hello humans dot co and
we'll link to that in the show notes
his episode with paul williams the
famed singer-songwriter was absolutely
incredible i was tremendously
impressed and i i do not say that
lightly i do not say it often because i
think most podcasts are just a become an
elephant graveyard of of you know two or
three episodes and the the effort put in
is very minimal but it was very clear
how well prepared sam was how
well-versed he was and how
emotionally connected he was to
paul when they were speaking it's just a
spectacular episode so i do want to
encourage people to check that out and
go to hellohumans.com
and i want to
then return to your july 4 to 6 blackout
and
what you mentioned
and i'm paraphrasing probably was that
grace found you and my follow-up
question to that is what did that feel
like how would you describe
that experience
well
i can reference it by tying in the paul
williams podcast actually when
paul talks about having won the academy
award for the barbra streisand movie
where he's standing before 100 million
people being given the greatest accolade
that the entertainment world can bestow
on someone
and he stood there in that light in the
light of that and he said it bought him
24 hours
24 hours of of elevated
feelings
feeling good a feeling like he wasn't a
piece of [ __ ] he was drinking and using
and so
when i got clean and sober
i had three books published i mean i was
doing really well in the world dies i
live in the same county i was born in i
know everyone here i am loved out of all
sense of proportion i had three books
published they'd done really well and i
knew secretly that i was
a fraud and dying i just felt like i was
my soul was so besmirched
what i did with other people what i'd
done to women friends how i had
dishonored my own self and i got that it
wasn't out there in a great future
article in a local paper let alone on
the academy awards stage that it was an
inside job and that it was going to not
be available to me if i kept chasing
down
the fame and the fortune and the
attempt to be perfect at what i do
and i learned
pretty early on like july 7th i got
sober and i think
i realized by the end of that first
month i was very frail and i weighed no
pounds which i loved i also had a
massive eating disorder which i missed
because i was like 20 or 30 pounds less
but anyway
i realized that this my life had been
like greyhounds dogs at the races you
know out trying to outrun each other and
but that the dog who won actually had
caught up to a
battery you know with fake fur pasted to
it and that what that was what you win
or that it was like glengarry glen ross
and if you got second prize you got the
steak knives and i had that spiritual
awakening which was
as important as it gets that it's not
out there that it doesn't have to do
with what you can buy or achieve or
lease or own or date
and that it was going to have to do with
some kind of union
with your own truth and with your own
self
and it had to do with through that union
with a power greater than ourself and
the great universal energy
and
the bigger reality you know and
the first week of being sober i have to
say
was not a high point in my life i was
extremely anxious and kind of frantic
and it was my best friend and everybody
loved me when i drink i'm a really funny
sweet person and i sleep with everybody
so to give that up was kind of crazy and
you know i'd wake up really sick and i'd
think about having a beer
just to get all the flies going in one
direction and people like me when i've
had a couple of beers and and so i felt
like who will like me now
who will like me if i'm not chasing the
bunny at the greyhound track who will
like me if i'm visibly scared and
uptight and sad and it turned out that
these other women did
they said we're going to love you until
you can learn to love yourself and in
fact sam when when he was uh eight or
nine we were watching king kong the
jessica lang remake and he always said
this trippy stuff
but he watched it and he he turned to me
and he said
she loves him because she can see that
he's lonely
and i just wept when he said that that
jessica lange loved king kong because
she could see that he was lonely and
that's what really what the people
who helped me get sober and also at my
church i went to this i go to this funny
little failing church that's half black
and half white can hardly pay the
electrical bills and it was the same
thing i went there drunk and bulimic and
stoned and they loved me because they
could see that i was lonely but i
couldn't take it in until i stopped
self-medicating like you referred to
with over caffeination
once i was there and i was settled
with somebody who was really safe and
listening then i could begin to have
a more tender
gentle
feeling towards my own anxious and
disappointing self so i could see that
the anxiety was part of what was so
beautiful about me like for instance
when i was coming up i was very very
sensitive i think that's why i got
migraines but that was always i was so
shamed by the culture by my teachers my
my parents for being so sensitive there
was a book my parents read called the
overly sensitive child you know that
help parents not have to have their
lives ruined because their child saw the
cover of national geographic and that
the children in india had flies or were
starving to death had flies on their
eyes and it was all about trying to help
me not be the person that i was which
was very very sensitive and i was
gravely shamed for it
when i was got sober my friend tom
weston
told me these five rules of being human
that changed my life i'll tell you them
now that had to do with who i was and
how
why i was so shamed for being who i was
born to be the first rule is you must
not have anything different or wrong
with you
you just must not have anything
different about you or wrong second rule
is that if you do
you really have to get over it as
quickly as you can
you really have to fix that it's really
a problem
the third rule is that if you can't get
over it or fix it you should just
pretend that you have that it's really
not an issue anymore
the fourth rule is that if you can't
even pretend to have corrected it you
should just not show up because it's
just so painful for the rest of us to
have to see you in your current
condition
and the fifth rule is that if you are
going to insist on the right to show up
you should have the decency to be
ashamed
i was
toxic with shame from my earliest
earliest years
to 32 when i got sober and i covered it
up by being so successful and so
charming and just such a
snappy piece of cheese and when i heard
those words which are somewhere around
86 i realized i was home free that that
was the work i was gonna do was that i
was gonna insist on the right to show up
as is
with my funny hair with my funny thighs
with my
hypersensitivity with my big open heart
and i was not going to be ashamed and if
it was a problem for you then you were
going to have to go
i wasn't going to keep trying any harder
to get you
to see that i'm just totally
fabulous and unique
if it doesn't work for you it doesn't
work for you you know you know this not
everyone's going to like you and like
your work lots of people can't stand my
work either
the political people because i'm a
christian or in the and the christian
people because i'm the left-wing
activist you know people a lot of people
you must have gotten horrible put-downs
and criticism in the media sure and you
have to you know you go okay look thanks
for sharing and this is not a place
where i'm going to spend a lot more time
because i don't know how long my life is
going to be but i don't have time for
this kind of crap right totally so that
was how
i think that was an equation let's say
that help me know what my work on this
earth was going to be was that i was
going to stop trying to fix and change
and correct myself so that the culture
and society would think i was more of a
success you mentioned the backstory on
bird by bird you mentioned el doctoro
and the writing is like driving at night
with the headlights on
we talked a little bit not much about
shitty first drafts
and i'm actually going to ask you
a modified question based on a question
that sam asked paul which was something
along the lines of if you look back at
all the songs you've written
is there a line or lines that really
encapsulate your
life philosophy or philosophy something
like that and paul's answer was you give
a little love and it all comes back to
you meaning leaning into kind moments
and leaning in in that way having
immediate medicinal effects on yourself
and others
i'm just wondering if
after
writing so many books if there are
certain lines or passages or quotes that
really stick out as
either part of your life philosophy that
is critical for you or just part of your
fabric of being are there are there any
particular lines concepts or passages
that that hop out for you
oh boy
it might be hard for me to think of
anything on the spot but i know
a quote that i see
frequently around twitter the
twittersphere is that
everything will work again if you impl
unplug it for a few minutes
including you
so so please elaborate so that's that's
i was going to ask you a question about
that how does that apply to you and your
life
well it's so awful
to see yourself
tweaked and maybe failing which we all
do it's part of the human condition
you know like vonnegut said welcome to
the monkey house but we see ourselves
feeling crying or tweaking or twitching
you know we're getting a tick in our eye
and everything in us tells us to correct
it it's rule three
now rule two you should correct it as
quickly as possible and instead
what i need to do then is to just
stop
i mean that's why i tell my writing
students just stop just stop what you
you know stop living unconsciously
stop trying to force everything into
submission
and stop and what i mean is unplug
turn off your phone for five minutes you
can do it turn everything off if you
need to cry cry we're so shamed
into not crying growing up because i had
a mother from england if we started to
cry at the dinner table we went to our
room without eating and for me
crying has been the way home crying and
rage have been the way home
my parents never expressed rage not once
and they hated each other they were like
a harold pinter play with this very
clipped area died conversation
i've had to teach every woman i've ever
helped help get sober let alone all my
sunday school kids that to cry is going
to bring them back into the fullness of
their own selves it's going to
bathe them it's going to baptize them
it's going to hydrate them it's going to
water the ground at their feet where god
knows what funny seeds have been dropped
by birds and will grow with just a
little bit of water
so
to unplug for me sometimes means crying
usually for me to be on that forward
thrust or the rat exercise wheel is
because i am trying to stay one step
ahead of the abyss and i'm trying not to
feel my feelings i'm just trying to it's
mood altering for me to be so busy and
to be at such a high level of of a you
know conversation and achievement and if
i can just stop and unplug
i might start to cry i might start to
realize how furious i am and how scared
i am of being furious when i was coming
up in the 50s an angry woman was about
to get exiled believe me by about 61 an
angry woman was replaced by a cute young
woman who wasn't so angry you know about
61-62 because of hefner the men started
leaving and they left the angry ones and
they left the weepy ones and they left
the ones who didn't keep their weight
down so there were a lot of societal
constrictions on having emotions and
states of mind that were not pleasant
for the men to be around and for me it's
this kind of frantic need to do even
more and to do it even better
and i can you break down you know i
think all three of us you me and sam
have had periods that we would refer to
as breakdowns where we just ground to a
halt
and uh ran out of any more good ideas
and didn't even care
you know we're just kind of done
and from those places for me and i know
for sam
and i assume for for you tim that from
that and maybe not later that day or
thursday right after lunch there was new
life
there was transformative
renewal of some sort and so to unplug
means that you stop and your shoulders
sag and you sigh and your head drops
your shoulder and to anyone else to
anyone in the world it would look like
you're doing really badly
but what you are is like an electrical
car outside the health food store
plugging back in and everything like
everything literally works again if you
unplug it
that's the greatest truth i know now one
thing i'm famous for something i didn't
actually say which is sort of
embarrassing
but
it's like mark twain on the internet or
yeah
um
but tom weston again my jesuit friend
said years ago maybe 30 it was 30 years
ago because sam was two and we were with
tom in mexico and he said you can tell
you've created god in your own image
when he hates all the same people you do
and i i said it in one book and
attributed it and then a couple times i
didn't attribute it i have to say
embarrassingly enough and uh but most
people attribute it to me and i've spent
about 10 years saying it's not me inside
me now i don't care anymore and tom
doesn't care but that's a great line
that i would like to be known for
[Laughter]
you said something in passing a while
back that i want to come back to and
that was related to your anxiety
disorder and you said most of the time
it's it's treated well
what has been helpful
for
your anxiety disorder or anxiety overall
for you medicine
i um have a severe
biochemical imbalance i had it as a
child i had ocd
i had to turn light switches on and off
17 times before i could get into my bed
if there was any sound in the house
between the switching light switches and
the bed i had to go back and do it over
there was a system
my whole issue has been safety and
whether i was safe or not and i
basically never was
but i was also addicted to unsafe people
because it was about maybe getting it to
come out right this time
when i was coming up there was no
awareness that children could have
really
terrible
biochemical disorders where they would
have to spend a tremendous amount of
energy just getting to where a regular
kid without an imbalance would start off
like you and sam have both talked about
having severe depression at times
in the past and that's not something
you're kind of going to think your way
out of you weren't supposed to and it's
not something you're going to go to ask
for it's going to be something that is
going to be
holistic whole body spiritual
psychic physical and for me medical and
so i found a great therapist
so many years ago and he found a way to
help me
get more imbalanced so that i don't like
without
the medicine i'm on
i mean i have plenty of anxiety
everything i write about is how i i'm
how anxious i am and then when when you
and i leave i'm going to be really
anxious and think well this didn't go
well or my answers were too long or he
probably won't even run it so i have
plenty of anxiety but i don't have
constant thoughts that neil or sam or
jax will die which i have without
treatment as a part of my holistic
healing with from this anxiety disorder
i mean i still have ocd i'm going to
have it but i don't do the light switch
anymore so that's progress
not perfection
it's holistic i eat a certain way
i have prayer and meditation as very
important parts of my life
you know with my writing book you will
remember this i really believe that
discipline is the path to freedom so
that with writing students i never just
say oh just wait for inspiration wait
till you feel like writing i don't say
that and with myself i don't say wait do
you feel like meditating i don't think
well wait till prayer comes naturally i
pray
help me or thank you you know help me
i'm so crazy right now i'm so afraid or
i hate myself so much right now i'm so
afraid
i do my meditation as an act of freedom
and i tell the truth you know you and i
were laughing about how much we love
elizabeth lesser
and she had written a book about the
miracle
of telling people the truth
and it ended up being a book about that
that's published marrow it's called
she's the head of omega that was about
her sister's blood marrow transplant
that she was able to be the donor for
but i said it's such a great topic you
know blurting it out as a path to
healing and every day i can say that i
either tell neil
sam or my best girlfriend something
kind of awful
[Laughter]
kind of unseemly
that probably a person who is supposed
to have this spiritual
wisdom or some spiritual tools at any
rate you'd be surprised that she still
goes there but i tell them you know what
they say they say
oh thank you for telling me that i was
there tuesday and i told you and you and
i ended up laughing and laughter is
carbonated holiness and then we got a
bag of eminem so we drove around town
listening to the beatles and eating m
m's and we both got so happy so that
realm of telling it out saying it
telling one person for me
is how i let go of whatever's vexing me
you know people always say very sweetly
let go and let god and i just want to
stab him in the head with a plastic fork
like you're a baked potato because
obviously if i could like oh i would
have
you know and you hear in recovery that
everything we let go of has claw marks
in it but the way that i can
to a group of people or whatever and
when i tell it i get my sense of humor
back and i also i might get people that
tear up because i've trusted them with
my truth and they nod and they say me
too
and then we're i i get to hook into
something so much bigger than my own
troubled judgmental mind
so i'm going to jump on the m ms we're
going to come back to the
the claw marks in truth
and uh prayer
but we're going to begin with eminem's
so i in the process of doing homework
for this i looked at a number of
interviews and in one
feel free to correct this but i read a
bit about your writing process and here
in front of me i have it it's from
inlander i think that's correctly in it
it said inlander.com
i sit down quite early give myself short
assignments dot dot dot so i think it's
truncated as a quote and reward myself
when i finished a tough paragraph for
passage msnbc and some m ms no music or
noise
and i wanted to start with the last part
do you
still follow that rule no music no noise
you're right in silence yeah i do
i i'm i'm so easily distracted and
this is what my dad did you know and he
wrote in silence he got he was at the
desk at 5 30
every morning in his little study going
tap tap tap you know on his
old typewriter in silence and he loved
music and as soon as he got up he put on
coltrane or or mozart and loudly and got
us all up for breakfast but i write in
the silence yeah
and what are some of the
other rules that you have for yourself
when do you tend to
as you've mentioned i think you're a fan
of discipline and systems when it comes
to these things could you elaborate on
you know what early means for you and
could you give some examples of short
assignments
yeah early means for me nine
there's a lot of us living on this
property there's one my grandson goes to
school
goes to camp he comes over to my house
for breakfast there's a lot of animals
there's a husband
and so i kind of do everything that
might distract me i try to be at the
desk at nine there's a chapter i don't
know if you would remember it from bird
by bird on one inch picture frames and i
always had my students get each other
one inch picture frames and i have one
on my desk i could show you if we were
in my office and not sam's
so you look through the one-inch picture
frame
and you see one scene you see one thing
that happened you see the first time you
got in the ice water
of maine
the ice water
lake in maine when you were six years
old where the parents didn't dare to go
in and you and the kids wouldn't get out
and in fact were blue when you were
finally fished out and your teeth were
like those
wind-up dentures
and you just write that's all i'm going
to write well the critical mind that
neil writes about is going to say what's
the point of that what does that have to
do with anything where are you going to
use that right and you have to let the
critical
guy be the ethical consultant let him go
back to the library and read a book and
wait patiently and you write this one
scene that has to do with this one small
piece of lake
with a relative and your mom and your
dad and your brothers and a bunch of
blue cousins you know bright blue
shivering teeth chattering cousins and
how that was like one of your first
experiences of heaven
but the mind is constantly going to tell
you there's not really a very effective
or efficient reason for you to write
this that's what my writing students are
up against constantly that's why i think
i could help you with your novel if you
really want to give it a try because in
the beginning what you'll do is you'll
look through the one inch picture frame
and all you'll do is to start scribbling
down these scenes on a legal pad of of
moments
and memories and visions and experiences
camp when you were nine years old and
that one moment in college where your
life changed forever
in fact let me ask you tim was there a
moment in college when your life changed
forever
oh for sure i there were many but the
one that actually comes to mind is
pretty dark if you're okay with dark oh
dark
dark are us
it was
it'll require a little bit of of preface
but i had taken a year away from school
to
work at several jobs and also to buy
time to finish my senior thesis
and i had come to believe for a host of
reasons that i've i've written about
if people are interested uh they can
find it if they just search my name and
suicide some practical thoughts
but i had really landed my place in a
very dark
abyss of hopelessness and
had not just
not just thought about suicide but
actually by that point decided i had
planned it i'd put it on the calendar
and
was
i would say a week 10 days away from
implementing the plan it was pretty well
thought through quite creative
and
i had
requested a book from
firestone library
at princeton where i was
well not then but had just been an
undergrad
about
euthanasia or suicide something like
that but i'd forgotten to update my
mailing address with the registrar and
as a result thank god for this but
when they mailed out a physical postcard
so in today's digital age i wouldn't be
here
when they mailed out a physical postcard
to say your book has arrived for pickup
it went to my parents house and my mom
got
this index card this postcard and called
me to ask me about it with this
quavering voice and
that snapped me out of this spell that
i'd put myself
under
and
that was the wake up call that snapped
me out of it and
certainly
things changed at that point very
quickly could have turned out
differently but that's that's the one
that comes to mind well that's an
amazing memory and that's the memory
that almost anyone who read it would
would have a experience that where the
details were completely different but
where they they grocked it you know they
got how you felt sam at hello humans
wrote a piece about a terrible terrible
breakup years ago maybe six years ago
where he ended up at the bridge you know
and he wasn't climbing over the side but
he was in the parking lot it's pretty
close for a mom and when he wrote it
hundreds of people said
thank you
you know i have felt like that
i have been there i don't live in san
francisco so i wasn't at the golden gate
but i was on you know i was wherever
they were so if i were your writing
partner i would say will you tell me
that story on paper and write it really
badly you know it's gonna be six pages
and by the time i edit it i'm gonna let
you use three of them
but write it long and badly
just write it just do it now you can do
it just in an hour
okay
that's what i would do so that's how i
talk to myself when i'm working that
that's an incred these memories are just
so
deep in our souls like they're not
obviously for entertainment values their
soul stood the stuff of the soulscape
and the cycles that we passed through
and
so beautiful
so that's what i do that's what the one
inch picture frame in the short
assignments how they work i do a new
thing you'll like this i decided an hour
at a time is too long
and
45 i do these things now i call pods
and they're 45 minutes long and they're
based on the one inch picture frame but
so if you write for 45 minutes you can
get 30 minutes of work done that's just
what the logarithm is that for 15 of
those minutes are kind of twisting and
turning trying to figure out a way out
of having to write it all and how
anybody in their right mind would see
that you shouldn't have to write for 45
minutes well nobody cares if you or i
write again you know
the weed better
and so but then i use the bribes and the
threats and the m ms and the msnbc at
the end of every pod to get 45 minutes
an hour to get 45 minutes written that's
what it is that's the equation so an
hour-long pod gets you 45 minutes two
hours gets you an hour and 15 minutes
this is just realistic it's it's not
efficient it's not what your teachers
taught you it's the spiritual creative
artistic life it's loopy and it doubles
back and it's like a mobius strip and
it's three steps forward and two back
but you got to sit there because
you got to keep your butt in the chair
and because no one in your family is
going to be glad to hear you're writing
a memoir or an autobiographical novel
anyway another thing i know a quote
that uh back to a question about half
hour ago but this also has to do with
our writing and this
writing down your memories writing the
truth i said you own everything that's
happened to you
if people wanted you to write more
warmly about them they should have
behaved better
[Laughter]
well in other words you also you can
write it all down any abuse any neglect
that caffeinated neglect that was so
common
all of it
everything you saw
and we can take it out later or you can
make it be happening to another family
that's why fiction's so great but it all
belongs to you you own it you get to
write it and um and we'll figure it all
out later that's what i always tell my
students look we'll figure it all out
later because they don't want to hurt
their families i had a student whose
mother used to
hold his hand over the flame when he had
disobeyed her on the stove but you
didn't want to hurt her feeling she was
an elderly woman by then and i said
make it be the family across the street
that you are best friends with have
their mother be the one
you own it she should not have done that
to you and you own it you get to work
with it you get to use it see the voice
that critical voice every step of the
way
is going to be explaining reasons why it
doesn't matter if you write it that
you're beating a dead horse or that
you're going to hurt people's feelings
or any number of reasons why to keep you
from writing but if you have this thing
inside of you if you're not writing then
you're not whole
you have to ask yourself how alive am i
willing to be and if you're willing to
be really alive then you've got to write
your truth you got to tell your stories
you got to do this deep union with self
or you have to ask yourself why am i
even here what's the point
let me ask you a question
about the blue cousins in maine
and i'll make it personal so i've
written two
fiction short stories
which is not many but two in the last
few weeks
and the first was really easy for me to
complete which i was surprised by but it
was it was almost entirely based on
real events so the first 75 percent was
basically
taking the the
true events and sort of putting them in
a different wardrobe but it came out
very easily
and then i had to fuss with it and have
a few cups of coffee to figure out the
rest but in in the process of a few
hours i was able to write a a two-page
short story very short
and then i decided well let me try
something that's really
more from the
imaginary realm and this this proved to
be i think going to the deep end of the
pool without my floaties on my arms
maybe a little too early
and uh and i got into this story that
i'm
that i've been working on and i'm five
six pages in and i'm just like where is
this going i have no [ __ ] idea how to
wrap this up what's the point of it so
all these voices
my specific question is
if i don't know where it's going and i
have no idea what to do and therefore
i'm even more prone to putting off the
writing for polishing my tennis shoes or
fixing the doorknob or whatever excuse i
can come up with
would you personally for you or your
students just start writing anything at
all to get the hands moving even if it's
not related to the story in other words
if you're halfway through
some larger project but you really don't
know what to do will you just write on
something that's completely unrelated
well i believe that the people and the
material know who they are and what they
do
and that they need to trust that you're
a reliable narrator
and this brings me to a whole thing that
i could do an hour on which is that if
you grew up around alcoholics or the
mentally ill the first thing you agree
to is to not to see what's going on
right because it makes them so unhappy
if you notice so you agree you for your
whole life you disagree not to see
what's going on and so you lose the
ability to trust yourself as the
narrator of your own
story and so
the material and the characters
will
give you themselves and their actions
as they trust you
to get it right
and so for me that's why i really
believe in the quiet and the silence and
i can i taught my fifth the
five-year-olds in this writing workshop
close your eyes there's this screen on
the back of your eyes can you see the
people what can you tell me about them
so you can get very quiet and close your
eyes and go inward
and then you can ask the people you can
ask the characters what were you
thinking then
what did you feel your choices were why
were you not willing
to just say what was true and that you
had the answer they were looking for you
had the missing purse or you had
whatever you can ask them
tell me something about you and what do
you think in this circumstance would be
plaguing you here's the thing with the
story you might want to ask yourself
what's at stake like you're trying to
get to know these characters better you
can write it 20 pages on tim i'm
promising you this you can write a
20-page short story you can take out
eight pages
and then you can send me the 12 and i'll
edit it for you but the thing is that
something has to be at stake
so what is you ask yourself and your
characters what do they love most in the
world what are they at risk of losing
if they're not at risk there's no story
there it could be a child it could be
their sobriety it could be their life
but what what do they stand to lose
so ask them and you can look at them
maybe there's two or three main
characters and you ask them what
couldn't you lose and then you put some
pressure on that where that could be at
risk
and then you can see
how they in fact respond do they run
do they put their fingers in their ears
and go la la la la la do they drink only
you know
and these people inside of you know and
you can ask them but the main question
is
there has to be something at stake
in every story that any of us are gonna
you know you're the ancient tribal
storyteller and you've said
do you all have a minute i've got a
story to tell you and we sit around you
at the fire on the stones and you tell
us the story now we all love stories
about ourselves right that's what the
tribal storyteller tells and that's what
people like about my story is that
because they're they're the stuff in me
that i know is universal it holds up a
mirror to them
and so you say if nothing happens in
your story if nothing happens to their
the favorite character what's the story
it's not a story it's so if it's right
yeah
and then what you as the writer do is
mess with them they couldn't survive if
they lost their
partner if the partner left them that's
the single most driving force in their
life they couldn't function if they lost
their sobriety
that's what causes them to panic they
couldn't stand it if something happened
to one of their kids
lean on them and then you can keep just
closing your eyes and studying them you
know if you have two characters who hate
each other put them in an elevator that
breaks down you know and see how they
react
figure out what they can't stand to lose
and then you've got us on the ceo please
don't let that happen no
don't make that how it's gonna happen
what was it like having a documentary
made about you
that was so weird it was just so weird
i'm kind of not even comfortable talking
about it because
i don't like having pictures taken to me
let alone movies taken to me but for
about six months freda mock who'd made
the academy award-winning documentary
about maya lin and the vietnam memorial
wall in dc she and her family and a crew
followed me from place to place and
filmed me in interviews and performances
i did on stage and stuff and talking a
lot about being a single mother because
operating instructions was relatively
new and the one part of it i love i love
the stuff of my kid in it because it's
such such beautifully filmed
home video but the stuff of my mom is
just breaks my heart it's so lovely my
mom i've written a lot about her and she
was a handful she was i had to be her
mother from about four years old and
she got alzheimer's and that did not
improve the situation and frida
did a bunch of footage at the place that
my mom lived which was assisted living
independent and then assisted living and
my mom
she's very befuddled and overweight and
kind of an embarrassment if you were her
kid you know growing up
it's just so touching it breaks my heart
i love it so much that that is on film
but mostly
i don't know
you must hate seeing yourself on film i
mean i think anybody in their right mind
does
yeah i have all sorts of insecurities
when it comes to audio and video took me
a while just to be able to listen to
recordings of interviews with my voice
in them
i learned recently why
just as a side note why we don't hear
ourselves the way we think we sound and
it's because
when we speak
when we're the origin of our own voice
we're also getting the
vibration
of the skull and the bones
of the jaw and so on in her ear the
different components of that there's a
resonance of that vibration that
combines with the sound that then
reflects off of the walls and so on so
it is in fact a different voice the
voice that we hear in the voice that
others hear but
quite apart from that i'm wondering why
you agreed to to do the documentary i
don't know i have to say before i answer
that i was on rosie o'donnell's show 20
years ago and sam was watching the
replay when i got home from filming and
he listened and then he said very nicely
mom do you have a speech impediment
and i've never gotten over that and i
just believe i have a very severe speech
impediment but
wait what was the question again the
question was uh
yeah
yeah why do you agree to do the
documentary
i don't know i i think it was partly
that this i was a bit of a star [ __ ]
you know and that frida
academy award and then i could win the
academy award and i would at least be up
on stage when she won the academy award
and then i was always broke too and i
thought that it would help me start to
make more money
which it actually did
but it was all that kind of stars in my
eyes thing that was the only reason and
then she got really down and dirty and i
cried a couple times on film when she
asked about raising sam without a father
and and what the men who helped raise
him meant to us
how incredible the bond was between me
and sam and the men who stepped in to
father him he didn't meet his dad until
he was seven
that's what i live for is for the depth
to be revealed and i'm so sick of the
surface stuff and the performance art
[ __ ] that we parlay most of the time or
what duncan trestle calls he says when
you first meet me you meet my bodyguard
and what i live for are the comments on
film or in books when the depth of our
being is revealed
like when sam and paul williams do that
interview on hello humans they both weep
because they go into the truth of their
hearts and souls and their being and
their pain and their their realness they
do real
and there's nothing more beautiful or
touching you know the ancient greeks
called god or thought of god as the
really real
which is certainly not something that
modern day religion is very interested
in but boy is that really real you know
when you're in the presence of it and it
is a battery pack and it is
so
revitalizing it's thrilling it's
thrilling to be with the really real
whether it brings tears to your eyes or
it makes you stop for a minute and then
throw back your head and laugh
let's talk about prayer if you're open
to that because it's not something that
gets
talked about much on this podcast and
specifically i'm looking at
a number of quotes from your new book
dusk night dawn these were sent to me by
our mutual friend elizabeth lesser so
she she had some selects that she sent
to me and one of them is very simple
it's just one line
the greatest prayer comma
quote help me not be such an [ __ ] end
quote
so i'm using this as a segue into how
you pray when you pray what it means to
you this word prayer but perhaps we
could start with this example so help me
not be such an [ __ ] speaking to you
now
and hearing of your history of people
pleasing and
accepting the leftovers
it's hard for me to imagine you being an
[ __ ]
i imagine that you know you're you're a
pleasant drunk
you
are catering or have catered to other
people's needs
so what does that prayer
mean to you
it was really my dad's battle cry he was
an atheist both my parents were atheists
but he had this ethical
moral core both my parents said they
were very big in civil rights movements
and
and his thing was just don't be an
[ __ ] be kind
and they had no spiritual interest at
all in fact they kind of had a list of
who were the craziest religious people
of all
in order and who which christians were
crazier than you actually had to be
but their path was about kindness and
about service to others and they did
feed the poor and they did take clothes
to the cold they took warm clothes to
people that were cold on the street and
they did
give away what they could and but when
i'm an [ __ ] it's usually not that
flagrant because you know i have a i
have my appearance together i've got the
surface nicely burnished and what i do
you can ask sam or neil i get very quiet
and then i weaponize that quietness and
it's very scary
people find it very scary i hear but i
just i stop caring and i get very
judgmental and i'm very you know most of
the time i mean a lot of the time i'm
just in judgment because it's so much
more interesting than being in kind of
peaceful and mosing along and being
ferdinand the bull it's so fun to be in
judgment especially with a friend you
know and to be doing gossip and judgment
and so i think that that's fine and that
we get to be really human and and
whatnot i heard when i first got sober
the willingness comes from the pain
you know and the healing comes from the
tools of recovery and of of our
spiritual lives meditation prayer
walks naps
but the willingness comes to the pain
has really stuck with me and when i have
made myself toxic because i'm being i'm
acting in like i'm feeling like an
[ __ ] i'm in judgment i'm
done with somebody i'm sick of them
and i feel very cold and uncaring
towards them or i feel uncaring to whole
swaths of humanity
or i feel like tom said you know i
create you can tell you've created god
in your own image when you hate all the
same people he does when i'm in those
states i create a lot of pain for myself
it becomes kind of metallic and like
sheet metal inside of me you get you
know that cold
hard when your heart gets cold
and hard it's just so miserable and
again back to awareness you know as soon
as you have the awareness that you're
there then you can start to use the
tools that you have and for me it would
be prayer and telling somebody i'm
really stuck right now i'm in
hostilities and i'm in you know the
troubles like in ireland i'm in the
troubles i think i'm right i'd rather be
right than happy you know the buddhists
are always better
right or happy so i'd rather be right
okay but
or the great krishnamurti said when he
was asked where he found spiritual peace
and what his message was he said i don't
mind what happens you know and i mind
about half of everything that happens i
mind that he said that he doesn't mind
what happens and when i'm there
i need help and the help comes from
being the in the awareness that i'm in a
cold sheet metally place in my heart
and i either need the breath of the holy
spirit you know or i need my best friend
to drive around with me and we go get an
overpriced cup of chai somewhere and
maybe some carrot cake while we're there
and i need help and i deserve it and i
can ask for it you know people love
love love to be there for you and it's
for me it's so easy to save and fix and
to be the help because i was like a
flight attendant in my family as i've
expressed but um so hard for me to ask
her you know the great poet william
blake said we're here
to learn to endure the beams of love
and i just it's beautiful terrifying and
it's most beautiful
and it's terrifying
we're here to learn to endure the beams
of love i know you go through this with
your girlfriend that it's scary to be
loved it's scary to be forgiven it's
scary you know what it's scary to be
accepted as you are
it's just like what's the catch
i'm sure your family was just fine but
in my family that never came up you know
that unconditional love and acceptance
of who i was at any given time it was
usually about changing me
to be who they really hoped i'd turn out
to grow up to be
and so it's so
trippy
that just that one line and to practice
bearing it you know to practice bearing
it
your metaphor of the flight attendant
brings me
to this anecdote i'd read of yours
when you first hit the new york times
list and you called your mom and said oh
my god mom i hit the list and she
replied with oh huh anything else
which sounds brutal and certainly can be
extrapolated to influence so many things
and what you just said about the sheet
metal this
coldness is actually a feeling and a
response i'm very very familiar with and
it reminds me i wish i knew the
attribution somebody can find it but
i have a quote which really stuck with
me which was that
hate is not the opposite of love the
opposite of love is indifference
and
i've thought about that a lot
because i i suppose for many different
reasons and childhood experiences and so
on
from a very young age i became very
adept at instinctively dissociating yeah
and
it's it's really been
a project to work on that yeah because
it is it is second nature when you pray
do you have in case of emergency break
class ad hoc use of prayer do you
well in addition to sort of on the as
needed basis
do you have a routine of prayer at
different times of the day or a week or
anything like that i wake up and i pray
i say a prayer everything i wake up and
i pray a prayer from recovery about just
help me keep
my sticky fingers off the controls of
this spaceship you know help me move
and you know i know
i know as sure as i'm sitting here that
if i want to have really loving warm
feelings i need to do really loving warm
things and i can do them for myself i
can put lotion on the parts of my body
that i
don't love quite as much let's say and i
wish i'd remembered to go to the gym
after i had a baby but i didn't uh 30
years 32 years ago i i can do loving
things with me
acts
take the action
and the insight follows you don't think
yourself into having a warm generous
heart you act your way you do loving
things for other people and so i pray to
have that awareness i pray to be paying
attention to life you know all around me
to the golden crown sparrows that
migrate through my part of the woods in
the fall into the daffodils that are
only here for two months with their
crazy orange and yellow
clown frills and two to the little bit
of green shoots that somehow i don't
know how to break through the concrete
and to pay attention you know and as a
writer you know henry james said a
writer is someone on whom nothing is
lost so i pay attention and i get
material i scribble it down and i gather
like rags for the rag bag guy in my soul
which is what you're doing with your
writing right now you know you're
amassing like these squares to use for a
quilt that you're gonna crochet together
and there's some of them are
unbleached linen and some are silk or
velour or old piece of denim and you you
don't don't judge them you you amass
them so i pray to pay attention to life
as a kind of troops all around me and
i'll tell you one thing there was a guy
who helped a.a get
started who was not himself an alcoholic
he was a priest
this is 1935 and he said to bill wilson
who was one of the craziest people in
america at that time
he said sometimes i think that heaven is
just a new pair of glasses
and i think about that almost every day
because i can either have the glasses on
that are like x-ray glasses where i can
just see everything that's wrong with
almost everything really because i'm
good at that i've made a career of it or
i can put on the glasses where i feel a
lot of compassion for everybody and i
see how hard they're trying and i see
that they got dealt a really shitty hand
of cards and that they played it the
very best they could and i see with
these the better pair of glasses that
how much beauty is all around me it
blows me away
and it makes me free and it makes my
life much more expansive but i need to
remember and the way i remember is to
pray to have the good pair of glasses on
i love that
i would like to revisit
the incredibly named horrible bonnie
how did horrible bonnie come into your
life and
can you please paint a picture for us
who is horrible bonnie what are any
lessons learned or
benefits imparted from from time with
with horrible body and why on earth is
her name horrible bonnie so many
questions but please just
tell us the story of horrible bonnie
well her real name is bonnie allen and
she has been
my spiritual mentor since i got into
recovery
and she has been with me every step of
the way through early sobriety through
having a baby without a partner or a
scent in the world through
sam's mess and
through a baby sam's baby at 19 through
breakups through
custody battles through poverty
and every step of the way
she just sees so much blessing and she's
and it drives me crazy
and no matter what shape i call her in
which is to say in completely enraged
spoiled brat narcissist mode she says oh
dearest i'm so glad you called and that
you trust me with this that's why i call
her horrible bonnie because it just
drives me crazy
never get on the bus with me where we
just trap like she doesn't she wouldn't
trash trump with me and she loathed them
but what she'd see was that
incredible miracles and blessings were
gonna spring from the four years of
having trump and that she would have me
put on the good pair of glasses and see
what was springing from this you know
that was going to change the world
forever what was going to change me
forever what she helped me do is to find
my own inner donald trump who's
bombastic and self-righteous and
victimized
and it changed things for me it really
changed trump for me when i found my own
inner donald trump and it's that sort of
thing you see what i mean that you could
call her in rage and judgment and she'd
just wreck it for you you call her in
superiority he'll just wreck it for you
but i wanted to add one thing if you
don't mind when you were talking about
the disassociation because that's been
very very important for me and the inner
donald trump is a part of that that
horrible bonnie
helped me start
welcoming these people that i try these
parts of myself that i cannot believe
are part of me that i can't stand that i
recoil from and she had me start
welcoming them to the table to where
we're gonna have soup tonight and it
would be like
blanche dubois you know that my inner
blanche dubois would be somebody who pre
is a predator and who preys on people
because she has zero self-esteem zero
sense of self and she she uses her
feminine wiles and her
victim
to
to lure people in and to do for her what
she can't do for herself and to elevate
her sense of self and donald trump this
person this me
who really is such an [ __ ]
and to say you know what
you're a part of me
come we're going to have soup we're
going to have potato leek soup tonight
can have a bowl with us and to make
friends with it and you know this is
terrible it's probably the worst thing
i've ever said on the air
but about
four months ago knows more than that but
there was a fire in a place
in a town where i hate somebody i hate
an entire family
oh god i can't even believe i'm saying
this but i kind of thought good
i thought good
and i caught myself and actually laughed
out loud and i thought oh my god and
then i realized it was my inner maternal
grandmother whose name was jane she was
my mother's grandmother and they grew up
on the docks of liverpool they were poor
the husband was a dock worker he died
when my mom and her twin sister were six
and her mother who was named jane was
this cold
gimlet eyed person who just hated people
and who wanted bad things to happen to
people it was my inner jane and you know
what i said to jane we're having
minestrone tonight come eat with us so i
had like blanche dubois
donald trump
jane and but i also have these incredi
like my hero i found my inner amelia
earhart and i found it for married
couples it was kind of threatening that
i've gone so many places i've gone so
far in my career i've traveled the world
i've done things that might have been
hard if you were married and that i was
so brave to do that they might not have
felt brave enough to do and so i found
amelia earhart and i would kind of tamp
it down so it didn't make other people
feel bad about their own accomplishments
and i thought no i don't know how long
i'm going to live but i'm not going to
pretend that i don't have this
pioneering
crazily brave woman inside of me and so
i would say to amelia earhart we're
having portuguese wedding soup tonight
come eat with us and so you've got all
these parts of me
that i have cut off that i welcome back
on my path to wholeness
you know in the new book a lot of it is
about soul and maybe all of these people
are a part of what i would dare to call
seoul that my sunday school kids saw as
a the innermost russian nesting doll one
of my sunday school kids said he thought
it was a silvery snow globe in the very
center of me or like a kiosk from which
the world troops by and i say hi to
people and wave
and so maybe in the very center of me
there's not the person my parents wanted
me to be or who i pretend to be or who
everybody thinks i am but it's this kind
of hodgepodge thing that's too big for
one set of clothes and it's all the
beauty and all the quirk and all of the
damage and all of the everything and it
was exactly as it was meant to be
and it's like i can push back my sleeves
and live from there now live from my
heart live from
the heart cave live from
the table where all the people have
joined me for dinner
for soup
it sounds like whether it's
with the assistance of horrible bonnie
or on your own that
many of these
reframes are the practice of
sort of manifesting heaven as you quoted
earlier of putting on a different pair
of glasses and
i'm really glad that you paused to talk
about the
the
reintegrating of these parts
of yourself and
i have personally found
i would say related work with someone
named dick schwartz richard schwartz the
founder of something called ifs internal
family systems which is somewhat
strangely named but is very much along
the same lines to be incredibly helpful
and i was gifted
this right here you can see it because
we're on video which is actually a
small rectangular piece of metal that is
intended to be a bracelet that you strap
on your wrist and it's a quote from neil
donald walsh i believe is the correct
attribution the struggle ends when the
gratitude begins and i just i try to
look at this as much as possible
because it is so tempting to busy myself
with
tunnel vision looking
over the horizon of things yet to come
real or imagined but
at the end of the day man is this type
of reframe and the reframes you're
talking about such potent medicine
i would like to ask you about the title
of your new book
how and why
the title that you chose you you are
exceptional at titling books i must i
must tell you uh
and wordsmithing in that way it's very
impressive so how did you end up
choosing
this particular title
well my last book the book before this
was called almost everything thoughts on
hope so i've been traveling around the
world to
the country to bookstores and theaters
talking about hope and the people in my
audiences just did not feel a lot of
hope they felt sad and scared and they
felt very worried about trump and the
u.n climate change papers had come out
that were just devastating where the
climate scientists didn't really feel we
could turn this around and so
i really felt that as a as a driving
dream of mine to be able to tell real
stories from my own life and others that
would help people realize how hard
things could be but how good we are at
hard
and so i i always loved this novel by
gabriel garcia marquez called
love in the time of cholera did you you
probably read that in college i thought
it was just just as good as uh oh my god
my mind went playing never mind thousand
thousand years of solitude or 100 years
of solitude one of those it takes a
village but uh 100 years of solitude
we got there and so i kind of had that
as it was soul and hope in the time of
trump and the u.n climate change papers
and so i felt that we were very very
much had trends gone from the dusk of
climate disaster
to the night of a lot of craziness and
brutality
and hopelessness but that the dawn
always arrives and so i wanted to
be as fearless as i could be writing
about all three of those stages but just
helping people remember the dawn always
comes
you know and that and oh i heard
something tim i thought was beautiful
which was that twilight refers to dusk
and on twilight is the when the light is
fading and becoming night and twilight
is when the night is fading and becoming
dawn and so i wanted to write these
stories
that were as real as possible but that
that were as hopeful and real
as i possibly could
before we go though i want to give you a
writing prayer because i do have a
prayer when i write especially when i'm
writing novels which are hard
so i tell all my students
i pray
help me get out of the way
to write what wants to be written
because i believe the material and the
characters as i said know who and what
they are what they would do in certain
circumstances but this k-fucked radio is
playing and i'm trying to appear
where i want people to think i'm more
erudite than i am which i'm not i'm a
dropout i want people to think i'm more
literary than i am neil says that shapes
of truth he has 34 tips for writers and
one of them is if you think it sounds
really literary it isn't you know
it's overwritten
so help me get out of the way to write
what wants to be written inside me
i'll use that tomorrow morning
and
i was reading some
coverage and interviews related to dusk
night dawn and
at one point you
quoted a roomy poem
or a line from it at least which is
through love all pain will turn to
medicine
and
i just have to say that i view you as a
master
of using both love and laughter as
carbonated holiness to turn
your pain into medicine
for yourself i certainly hope and
believe but also for the people who read
your work and who
are exposed to you and i just want to
thank you for that i i know it takes
incredible
effort and focus it's not accidental
and i wanted to thank you for for doing
what you do
well thank you honey that's really sweet
and uh if i could pull a complete 90
degree turn just uh one more question
one or two more questions from me
complete non-sequitur
but
you seem to love movies you seem to
watch a lot of movies and
i would love to know if there are any
all-time favorites or movies that you
have watched over and over and over
again that come to mind
anything that this question prompts
related to films
that you might recommend or or a name
for people
i love movies more almost more than
anything
you know it's funny there's a
scene in the movie the mission with
robert de niro and jeremy irons which
most people didn't see except for the
they know the soundtrack by neo what's
his name
morris gone or something
anyway it's called the mission and in it
jeremy irons runs a mission at the in in
the rain forest above below these falls
where a tribe is being decimated and
robert de niro
is a soldier and he has killed a bunch
of people and he ends up
at the mission and he's got this huge
bag of weapons and everything that has
ever defined him
he and jeremy irons and another couple
of the brothers are climbing up past the
falls to where the tribe is it needs so
much help and robert de niro in it's a
scene it's five minutes it's not it's
nothing
he ends up talking to the
chief and the chief wants him to drop
the bag of weapons and he's not going to
they brought him to this point he's
exiled he's ashamed he's suicidal it's
the darkest darkest place he could ever
be but he won't let go of the weapons
that brought him to this place
and it's non-verbal they don't speak the
same language and the chief kind of does
these expressions and these faces and he
finally takes a rope and he cuts
this rope that holds the bag over robert
de niro's back and robert de niro begins
to sob
and they begin to laugh and cry together
and he buries himself into the chief's
neck
and it is one of the most profound
moments i've ever seen in my life
you know how we will not let go of the
stuff the weaponry and the stuff that
gave us the illusion of power
the illusion of control and domination
we just won't let it go it's so
beautiful there's many movies i mean i
love the godfather and i love i've
completely turned on woody allen so i i
don't watch him with any pleasure
anymore but up until about 25 years ago
i had seen all of his movies five and
ten times
what are your favorite what's your
answer to that question
all right i'll buy i'll buy you some
time i want to i want to hear some more
from you i'll mention a few
uh there are the movies that i'm
embarrassed to admit i'll give one that
i'm not embarrassed to admit and then
i'll give a few that i am the first is
an animated movie called spirited away
by
hayao miyazaki that's how you would say
his name in english it's it's just a
mesmerizing
fantastical film and it's so deeply
layered i lived in japan as an exchange
student for a year with fam japanese
families went to a japanese school
and it just
sparked so much
imagination and nostalgia and optimism
in me that's that continues to be one of
my favorite movies of all time
for each book that i've written
i tend to have one or two movies that i
play in the background on mute
because i find writing to be such a
solitary experience so i'll have a
standing desk and then i'll have a
screen or a projector of some type with
a movie playing in the background but it
has to be a movie that i'm very very
familiar with or it'll be really
distracting so for the first book the
movies were
shawn of the dead which is a comedy and
the born identity the firstborn identity
then
for
let's see i think it was
i think it was for our body the two
movies were
casino royale the james bond film and
then
babe
about farmer hoggett and the linda pig
and i came to really appreciate babe it
is it is a nuanced
hilarious
movie
but if i had to choose one that people
might not recognize that i think is
really beautifully shot and
packed full of lessons although often
they are interlaced with brutality
there's a movie called the prophet i
don't speak french but it's french so um
something like that
about i want to say
i'm going to get the ethnicity
wrong but
a young
man slash boy who's incarcerated
and
is taught the ways of sort of the prison
power dynamic and power dynamics by i
want to say the corsican mafia and it's
about his
his ascent
and his troubles and his wins
leading
up to the
sort of grand finale of the film and
it's beautifully shot it's very brutal
but
i feel like there's also a fair amount
of beauty in that film so those are a
few that come to mind are there any
others that come to mind for you you saw
my octopus teacher right i did i did
favorite movies you know there's a movie
i've made sam and my grandchild watch
that that changed my life it's called
babazis the persian movie from do you
see it from it's iranian
the second name is a-z-i-z but it's like
b
a
b
b apostrophe a b a z i z and it's about
a you know it's the great classic theme
of a uh it's a travel log with a very
young girl
and yeah it's b a b.a.b apostrophe
a-z-i-z
and the subtitle is the prince that
contemplated his soul and it's a movie
within a movie about a very little girl
taking her extremely aged grandfather to
a festival of holy men where you begin
to understand he probably is going to
die
it's about all of life it's about life
and death and despair and renewal and
and crisis and death and resurrection
and new life and
people and food and
it's about an hour and a half and it's
hallucinatory and it changes you on a
molecular level i am not making enough
that's going to be on
deck for this evening probably i'll see
if my family will be game to watch it
well annie this this has been such a
pleasure is there anything
that uh we haven't covered or anything
that you would like to say or any
requests you'd like to make of my
audience before we wrap up of course
people can find you at
anne lamotte on instagram twitter
facebook it is anne lamott and we will
link to the books and the social
websites documentaries everything we've
discussed in the show notes at tim.log
slash podcast but is there anything you
would like to
add before we close up for this first
conversation
oh i'm not sure i would like to tell one
quick story if i might
or
people who
both believe in a higher power and
people who
believe in goodness and who believe that
there is
some sort of loving energy in this world
that bats last
uh i would call it grace but
this woman in my recovery community
about 15 years ago had a very severe
oral cancer she'd had to have part of
her jaw removed in part of her tongue so
she had a really dramatic speech
impediment
she did the chemo and the radiation she
was fine she was in remission for almost
10 years and then it came back so she
shared a group level that she was going
to have to do it all over again maybe
have a bit more jaw removed and have
chemo and radiation
everybody just was so panic stricken and
uncomfortable about it they started
doing what you do which is saying oh my
beautician's son had that same thing and
he's fine now and oh this and oh that
and oh oxygen therapy and she just waved
it away like it was cigarette smoke and
she said you know what god's got it
and so i got that
actually written on a engraved on a gold
coin that i wear around my neck that i
touch
constantly to remember that i'm not in
charge of much except for maybe helping
the animals get the cans of cat food and
dog food open every night because they
have no possible thumbs but i just know
that whatever you think of god you know
good orderly direction or group of
drunks or grace over drama or
whatever that life tends and tilts
towards the good and that we're cared
for all evidence to the contrary every
step of the way we really are we're
surrounded emily dickinson
said that hope causes the good to make
itself apparent and we're surrounded by
that good and we're safe that's why i
tell my sunday school kids you are loved
and you are safe so that's what i'd like
to leave everyone with
well that is the perfect place
to bring this to a close and
once again annie i feel very privileged
and
happy that
after all of these years after you
helped me from afar
in my time of need
that we're able to have this
conversation and i had a an absolutely
wonderful time and took a ton of notes
and will be watching and looking up many
things so thank you again for taking the
time
thank you so much tim i loved it
you